je suis tellement curieuse veut avaler
la vie je veux tout faire
je veux tout tenté je veux tout essayé
et puis ces textes tellement ils sont en
vacances 10 hommes et enfin le moment
voisine on est derrière eux
[Musique]
je suis bientôt spica comédienne je suis
né à montréal le 3 juillet 1929
j'ai donc 90 ans j'ai 90 ans et demi
j'aime la lecture la musique je joue du
piano
j'aime communiquer avec des amis et par
téléphone parce que on facebook le jeune
que soi ya deux choses que j'aime par
dessus tout c'est le champagne le vrai
j'aime le bridge
j'aime les voyages quand je suis seul je
fais des casse tête j'avais des mots
croisés et surtout ce qui est important
pour moi c'est de continuer à apprendre
j'ai toujours été très curieuse et un
piano alors donc je vais jouer
il est très facilement aux sablons faty
les enfants l'eau il ajouté après nov
il s'amuse à 6 à la vie pour eux c'est
un jeu et j'ai comme sa fille après
ledit bc - mieux c'est mon retour à
l'enfance
il ya des gens qui sont un certain âge
qui wallon j'ai toujours rêvé de sauter
en parachute et elles le font avant le
clown d'essayer des choses qu'on n'avait
jamais fait
on ya des délits poli pour l'arbitrage
en 75 matchs à disputer
il était à l'encan aa contre mon frère
est faux pour que je les en faut pour
progresser il s'en fout ça et je suis
resté là que j'ai puisé jusqu'à la fin
jon chu et jetés vivants
il ya des grandes périodes je peux plus
rien faire et ça ça me désolait
tellement tellement travaillé quand même
trouvé le moyen de faire quelque chose
parce que je me dis si je me laisse
aller serait finie et puis le bye bye
bull
j'ai revu le jour et maintenant ça va
très bien je recommence une deuxième vie
moi j'ai des projets pour jusqu'à 5 ans
et plus alors donc l'or tamouls a
maintenant d'autres vins de garde des
enfants
il ya des bâtons dans les roues et 40
nuits sont courtes
ils ont 60 ans qui a tué leur cocon 9e
minute par contre c'est peu mais moins
ce move troupes entrées sont au sol de
dérive sais pas ce que je vais vous cet
été
moi je vais je vais je vais quand même
rajouter à la sphère tuteurs des petites
jeunes vieilles c'est normal des fois il
ya un an des vieilles annonces des joues
blêmes en plus de vous des jeunes pour
serait plate d'être vieux et pas de
raison donc c'est pour ça que je dis
pourquoi on envisage la vieillesse avec
le sourire tout le temps
j'ai tellement important pour moi le
sourire vous ne verrez jamais de mes
photos non souriante
j'ai compris que derrière le sourire se
cache une joie de vivre
d'ailleurs pour ça que moi y'a des âges
que j'aime ces voies 90 vous dites votre
âge 97 sourire le plus rapproché nages
que je veux dire 195 qu'elle est
[Musique]
même si j'aime de facebook vous pouvez
même partager
[Musique]